i
[Música]
a
el informe sobre trabajo infantil de la
organización internacional del trabajo y
de unicef no contempla específicamente
la situación de brasil sin embargo
unicef considera que aquí también
aumentó esta lacra por causa de la
pandemia antes de la emergencia
sanitaria causada por el coronavirus en
brasil había un millón 750 mil niños y
adolescentes de 5 a 17 años que tenían
que trabajar de ellos 706.000 padecían
condiciones duras de trabajo según datos
oficiales del propio gobierno brasileño
además hay que citar un elemento racial
en este país porque el 66 por ciento de
los menores trabajadores son negros
estas cifras oficiales no contemplan sin
embargo a los niños que trabajan
regularmente es decir a través de
contratos de formación
[Música]
pero viene ejecutando su plan nacional
contra el trabajo forzoso sin embargo
diversas centrales sindicales advierten
que existe falta de presupuesto para su
aplicación según cifras oficiales en el
país más de un millón de niñas niños y
adolescentes entre 5 a 17 años han
trabajado en el perú los expertos
señalan que el 88% del trabajo infantil
se encuentra en el área rural y agrícola
pero también sostienen que la pandemia
del cobi 19 obligó a muchos menores que
estaban expuestos al trabajo en las
calles continuar sus labores a puertas
cerradas paralelo esto en el sector
educación se calcula que 300.000
estudiantes dejaron de ir a la escuela
en el 2020 el 75% fue por problemas
económicos la defensoría del pueblo
recomienda al país que lo ideal es que
ningún menor de edad trabaje y en lugar
de ello se los impulse a estudiar
algunos colectivos sociales reportan que
lamentablemente las recomendaciones
muchas veces se quedan en el papel
[Música]
la pandemia por kobe 19 ha provocado que
8.4 millones de niños en el mundo se
sumen a las filas del trabajo infantil
según el más reciente reporte conjunto
de la organización internacional del
trabajo y la unicef
de acuerdo con américo furtado de
oliveira director para la oficina de
méxico y cuba de la oit no hay aún
cifras en méjico del impacto que ha
tenido en la epidemia de coronavirus en
el trabajo infantil sin embargo se
espera que este habrá aumentado y es que
la situación ya era alarmante desde
antes de la pandemia pues según el
instituto nacional de estadística y
geografía en su más reciente encuesta
nacional de trabajo infantil en 2019
había en méjico 3.3 millones de niños en
situación de trabajo infantil los
estados que tienen mayor presencia de
este fenómeno en el país son oaxaca
chiapas y puebla
[Música]